how's the gum rancid today we're gonna
play games buying I'm actually excited
let's start off with the classics duck
simulator 2014
god damn this game looks [ __ ] amazing
oh my god
it's Scrooge McDuck in Sweden we call
him you working for Anka bet it barrels
are on my side in a dark universe what I
quash stomachache he will hit on the
helium ironic Marauder
the soundtrack is so [ __ ] insane I
can't even you know what that's a game
that I could actually like play this
game was made by Activision that so
that's how you know it's good starting
to think this game is not about deaths
starting to think this is a homoerotic
porno with beards this is anything wrong
with beards being homoerotic hey there
is dogs yes the legends were true listen
to those noises they must have used the
audio samples of the beta testers of
this game their cries echoes through the
forests wait my name is jean-luc
my name is jean-luc and I look like this
and it looks like I've [ __ ] myself I
don't know if I'm ready can I really
kill another one of myself
get rekt noobs
do you ever know that you're my hero you
are the wind beneath my ears I had been
up the duck so long I forgot what it was
oh god it's been too long I understand
I'm scared now you got me the
interesting tale of that was another
hardcore dancing of the club should I go
home with the nofa prostate not gonna go
home with the local prostitutes nice
tits though this game is practically my
life not the toilet and broom what do
you want this time push doggy I swear to
god oh right you know what what if I go
home with a prostitute maybe that's it
all right Miranda don't puke all right
[ __ ] it - I had done worse - come in
those your shoes or did you [ __ ]
yourself don't want to know I don't
[ __ ] get it so this is like 3d duck
hunt
that's kind of Awesome actually you
flagged so far to lose it
like click on ground to move mama duck
no no no no I'm fine ah all right wicked
just uh just believe in yourself [ __ ]
we're dead I'll be good
everything is good people don't
understand how [ __ ] hard it is to be
a DA all right come on oh no Lisa Lisa
would you rather fight one hundred
duck-sized horses or one horse-sized
duck one horse-sized duck definitely oh
my god this is it this is what my life
my life all my choices everything I ever
died for still live up to this moment to
defeat that mother [ __ ] die
verbatim of police [ __ ] [ __ ] giant
ass done yeah you might be a tough one
but I have a moustache and I put many
cheer on a damper on ass duck
don't use the ass attack I don't know
how to copy flies it's like well I know
a [ __ ] but I encourage and you will
activate me it's just not your dirt is
for Schrader
maybe like to kill a duck leave a life
to save a duck and I will see you next
one stay awesome brass